[Music]
Eric it's a pleasure to sit down with
you again they were good to see you
so last time we met in person we
recorded a piece that ended up being
glitching the matrix - which was the
origin story of the intellectual dark
web was it was sort of a deep dive into
your thinking and then why the
intellectual dark web was or your take
on why the intellectual type what was
needed why it was timely why it was
really important and since then you've
launched the portal we were talking
before about the portal before we
started recording and you said that you
felt that it kind of kicked into a new
gear in the recent episodes episode 18
episode 19 19 was a recent episode with
Bret your brother Bret Weinstein the
evolutionary biologist what you talked
about things called all all our mics are
broken which is a really fascinating
story it was a really really fascinating
episode and you slight reference to one
of our submarines is missing so you
introduced a concept called the disc in
the previous episode in episode 18 and I
think you you've also said that it's
relevant to what has happened with with
19 especially the app the aftermath like
the follow-ups or the lack of follow-ups
do you want to talk a little bit about
what the disc is and why you think it's
so important sure if you went back to
the first Matrix movie let's say clearly
it's a sci-fi thriller would you have to
ask yourself was it fiction at all is
the reason that that movie did so well
and played so well that in fact it
wasn't fiction but metaphor and I think
that there's some point at which
Morpheus starts describing the matrix in
the film as a prison that you cannot see
taste feel or touch or something like
that in some sense the disc works like
this we've lived our entire lives in a
medium and that medium has to do with
the way in which our ideas are
suppressed so Bret you were recently on
Eric's podcast the portal for an episode
called all our mice are broken which is
a long story really fascinating I've
heard a lot of people say it was one of
the most fascinating podcasts they've
ever heard if it's a detective story
it's a story that has kind of huge
ramifications for medical testing and
it's yeah it was really really well told
and it also has a lot of really
interesting dynamics between you and
Eric as well commiserations thank you
I'd really urge anyone to go away and
listen to that because we don't want to
recap the whole story here but I'd love
to hear what has happened since whether
there's been any because one of the
other questions that it brings up is
what stories are being covered by and
beyond registering in sort of the the
mainstream and which ones are
disappearing without trace and why they
might be disappearing without trace
and what Eric's called the disc the
distributed information suppression
complex yeah maybe we could talk about
like what effect it's had and just sort
of sub without summarizing the whole
story why this is significant so the the
important piece of the story from the
perspective of your audience and the
rest of us is that when I was a graduate
student I was working on a question that
involved cancer senescence and evolution
and I stumbled on a result in the
literature that I had to grapple with
that didn't fit with my hypothesis or
anything else
and as I wrestled with it that the
conclusion was that all mice or in some
cases all rodents were thought to have
long telomeres telomeres are repetitive
DNA sequences at the ends of chromosomes
and at the point that I was doing this
work in the late 90s they were
understood to shorten every time a cell
divided so in a Cell divided its DNA to
copy it a little bit of the telomere was
lost each time and there comes a point
at which a cell has a small enough set
of repeats in its telomere that it no
longer divides I was working on the
hypothesis that these shortening events
were actually a protection against
tumors and cancer and that the downside
of that system of
cancer protection was that our tissues
couldn't repair themselves indefinitely
and we grew old and feeble with age and
ultimately died the problem was that
with the conclusion that all mice have
ultra long telomeres this could not be
made sensible because mice have short
lives and if they have telomeres that
are ten times as long as people they
should have the ability to replace their
tissues and they should be very
long-lived so the podcast recounts the
story of my increasing suspicion that
there was something wrong with the
conclusion that all mice have long
telomeres and my contacting a researcher
Carol Greider who then tested that
hypothesis with her graduate student at
the time Mike Heymann and they
discovered that in fact mice that is to
say wild mice don't have long telomeres
and then it's only lab mice that do have
long telomeres as I had predicted the
most important outgrowth of that
conclusion is that there's a problem in
our drug safety system because our drug
safety system utilizes laboratory
rodents especially mice to test the
safety of drugs before they're ever
tested on humans our mice which have
been altered by the environment in the
laboratory breeding colonies from which
laboratories get them our mice have been
altered by evolutionary forces in those
colonies so that they have effectively
an infinite capacity to replace damaged
tissue and a an incredibly extreme
vulnerability to cancer in other words
they eventually get cancer and their
tissues do not grow old right because
their telomeres are so long when you use
those animals in order to test a drug a
new drug to see whether it be safe to
give them to people you get a
paradoxical effect
or at least the hypothesis suggests that
the effect should be that the damage
that is done to those mice by these
drugs unless it is so extreme in the
moment that it kills them outright will
not be harmful to them because mice
unlike us can replace their tissues
indefinitely and in fact because these
mice seem to all get cancer if you let
them live long enough a poisonous drug
may actually extend their lives because
it functions as a kind of chemotherapy
so the not so funny joke taught at old
in in chemotherapy wards is that the
whole purpose of chemotherapy is to kill
the tumor faster than you kill the
patient right tumors are more vulnerable
than regular tissues because their DNA
is constantly dividing and when DNA is
dividing it is vulnerable in a way that
DNA that is paired is not and so these
mice are suffering from unusual cancer
load and a poisonous drug that actually
damages cells that are vulnerable will
actually interrupt their cancers ability
to grow and so they may actually live
longer than their their non drug
counterparts in any case though the
result of this is that you will
administer drugs in high doses to mice
to see whether or not they are poisonous
mice will not respond the way people do
because of their unusual telomeres which
have evolved to belong in the laboratory
colonies and then when you release the
drug in into the human population these
toxins will do damage in our bodies
which will be particularly visible when
it affects the heart because the heart
has a low capacity for cellular repair
and when the heart fails it's very
noticeable so the idea is that something
like Vioxx which turned out to be
destructive of heart tissue was released
into the public because our mechanism
for testing whether it would be safe in
mice head
thus there are quite a number of other
drugs that have shown the same pattern
we thought they were safe they were then
released they turn out to do heart
damage they're pulled from the market or
warnings are appended to them so the
question is have we made an error where
something about our laboratory
environments is creating mice that make
drugs look much safer than they actually
are and causing us actually to to suffer
pharmaceutical harm that is unnecessary
you asked what the outgrowth of this
podcast had been there was tremendous
interest in it online on YouTube and on
other social media outlets and bizarrely
there's been no reaction from anybody in
the Academy or in the press in the
mainstream press there's some very
strange thing where nobody seems to want
to engage the issue that there was a
first principles prediction coming from
evolutionary theory that seems to have
radical implications both for our
understanding of death and for the way
in which we use the mouse model to test
all sorts of things
the mind reels I just can't I can't
fathom that given the amount of interest
in this story and this this video is
just sort up the charts it's now over a
hundred thousand views there must be two
hundred and fifty thousand downloads you
know they came very quickly many people
have heard it and the interesting thing
is how interested everyone is in the
story and how the interest is least in
the place that you would expect it most
I would imagine if this was a long story
we would be hearing nothing but
chortling from the molecular biology
community telling us how badly we've
understood what in fact is going on or I
would want to understand from the news
media tell me why is this uninteresting
to you I should say that I've named
these sorts of stories anti interesting
anteye interesting story isn't really
uninteresting the more riveting the anti
interesting story gets the less interest
there is from the official channels and
why why do you think that's the response
from from journalism why let's start
from molecular biology why do you think
this is about response from molecular
biology or from the scientific community
well let's think about it what if you
had 20 years of studies that were built
around a mouse model which was known to
be broken and that in fact you had
people who were trying to say that the
mouse model might be broken and we need
to have a discussion about this
immediately and the community had
decided that it didn't want to introduce
the idea that this might have
far-reaching implications perhaps many
results that we have based on the use of
these mice are off you could have a
thousand strains but if they share a
common breeding protocol you might have
a situation by which all of those
strains are affected because they're all
subject to the same ideology that the
the breeding rotation is in fact an
evolutionary environment and that
telomeres adapt rapidly unlike protein
coding regions so my belief is is that
if you really don't want to shake up
your own I mean this is the typical
story if you don't have the ability to
shake up your own institution you tend
to want to throw these things under the
rug and hope that nobody notices with
respect to journalism I don't know I
mean journalists have gotten very
bizarre you talk to a lot of them
they're very excited about the story so
that my experience with journalists is
that you still have fresh faces who hear
something they'll tell you oh this is
fascinating it's fantastic I got to run
it down like getting all these partial
results and then very often you get this
weird phone call which is like my editor
said to stop working on it
well why they said it wasn't of any
interest well it might involve drug
testing it might involve why we died how
could you say that this isn't
interesting well that's what he said he
said it wasn't interesting to enough
people
too complicated like are you kidding me
I mean there's just no way of telling
this David I'm getting sort of almost
fatigued having to go through it
something has gone terribly wrong with
journalism and I just don't know of
anybody who's not sensing that I guess
trying to understand why it happened
from the sort of information site from
the journalism side journalism works by
dedicated or a story like this would
work but through a dedicated
investigative journalist who's willing
to sort of chase it down to stake sort
of to a lot of time and a lot of energy
in doing it so it kind of I certainly
feel that one of the things that's
happened in journalism it's become much
more of an information processing thing
rather than an information sourcing
thing like cutbacks on in in the numbers
of journalists and like probably the
skill level of journalists who used to
kind of in the 70s use the phonebook
make calls themselves it's like those
skills I think of definitely atrophied
to a degree look I have to be careful
about it if I wasn't careful about it
this is a very simple story yeah maybe
we released a lot of bad mice and that
now we've got health implications from
the fact that our mice model is all
screwed up and that we had people who
didn't want to give credit where credit
was due and so we didn't get the
hypothesis that explained what the
potential ramifications are
full-stop yeah right somebody may have
figured out why we died is that of any
interest to you is it too complicated I
don't buy any of this if you're smart
enough to watch Game of Thrones of The
Sopranos you're smart enough to follow
this story if you if you really can't
follow more than one plot line at a time
and you need everything in all caps and
really big type then maybe you're not
the target audience for this but as long
as people subscribe to the I don't know
The Economist or The Times it would
appear if we don't have a world that's
smart enough to follow this story we've
got a lot of bigger problems than T
lemaitre's I don't think this is very
difficult and I'll be honest I think
that these excuses about budgets are
absurd I could do this in my spare time
if I wasn't actually a participant in
the story
just to summarize like for people who as
soon as you say the word telomere start
to kind of glaze over and like I'm
really struggling to follow the story
which which I think many of us are like
let the ins and outs of it why is this
so significant well it depends what you
mean by this there are two this's
there's what goes on in a normal mammal
with respect to telomeres senescence and
cancer and then there's what happened in
the scientific study of telomeres so
those are two very distinct stories and
I really wish that we could talk about
the scientific story in isolation from
the big science story because the big
science story is a very different it's
about human failings more than anything
else whereas the scientific story is an
absolutely fascinating story that
explains who we are and why we're built
the way we are and it really needs to be
more broadly understood the problem is
you can't really understand the
scientific story unless you understand
how the human story was preventing it
from emerging the two stories have
become intertwined in a way that they're
almost impossible to disentangle and so
anyway that that's one of the things
that emerged on this podcast the import
the import of the scientific story is we
do not understand that we are the
beneficiaries of a system that very
almost ideally balances two conflicting
deadly hazards one hazard is tumors and
the other is wearing out we have a
system in which we don't have to wear
out because our tissues can replace
themselves but if you let that system do
its own thing then every cell almost
every cell in your body is in danger of
turning into a tumor that will kill you
if you correct for the problem of tumors
that can run away and crowd out vital
organs then you create a limit on the
amount of tissue repair you can do and
understanding that human beings are
actually extremely well built in this
regard we are the longest live
terrestrial mammal by far as a result of
the fact that the system has been built
to give us very long life so the entire
question about extending maximum human
lifespans should happen in this context
we've had our lifespans radically
extended since our branching point with
other mammals right natural selection
has already worked on this puzzle and it
has given us a very effective adaptive
balance between these two hazards you
can definitely have tissues that replace
themselves better but you'll have more
cancer risk right and you can definitely
have less cancer risk but then you'll
have tissues that don't replace each
other replace themselves very
effectively and the question is could we
adaptive leaf shift that balance a
little bit we could would it be
desirable
there are even scenarios in which it
might be for example if we got very very
good at spotting tumors when they had
just started right well then you might
be willing to have more tumors start and
then to address them surgically in
exchange for tissues that age less
quickly that's conceivable we could do
that and you know if that's what we're
gonna do we should pursue it but we
should not pretend that what we are
pursuing is an end to human agent if
that's not going to happen right it
can't happen so that's the scientific
upshot the social upshot the sign the
science the big science upshot is that
the market has interfaced with
scientific study in ways that are
absolutely devastating the way that the
mouse telomere got extended had to do
with market forces that rewarded the
production of mice at a very rapid rate
in order to produce mice at a very rapid
rate a decision was made to breed only
young animals and breeding only young
animals had a dramatic selective effect
in the colonies it would appear
that was one way in which the market
interfaced badly with the story the
other way it seems to enter face badly
with the story has to do with
flourishing in an academic environment
by keeping quiet with respect to hazards
like this and it had to do with the
scientific apparatus serving the
interests of potentially the
pharmaceutical industry at the expense
of the public I'm pretty sure the
pharmaceutical industry did not know
that the mice were broken in a way that
bias to drugs in the direction of
looking safe until until I pointed it
out however after that point they did
know and they had a question did they
want to solve the problem at some large
financial cost to their industry or did
they want to sweep it under the rug I
have no idea whether pharmaceutical
companies have actually taken action but
what I do know is that the system is
sensitive to the kind of money that the
pharmaceutical industry brings to bear
and that it would not be surprising if
they are functioning as the ghost in the
machine that prevents the story from
ever emerging in the mainstream press
yeah I guess I'm slightly more hopeful
because I I know I've worked with
journalists who have followed particular
stories at significant personal risk put
their careers on the line to kind of
pursue especially in foreign affairs
stories of huge important so I'm hopeful
that journalism is not as compromised as
maybe we're kind of sketching out to be
David I just want to say something about
that I've been following the story for
20 years we've intermittently tried to
get interest in the story it's not
difficult to locate reporters who find
the story to be of interest that's not
where the problem appears to be located
there is something above the level of
the reporter that causes the story to
die usually and I think that the disc is
much more located in the editorial later
rather than in the actual beat reporter
layer one possibility David is is that
the editorial layer is taking into
account different sorts of decisions
that the journalistic layer is still
being told go pursue the stories that
are important
that are interesting and bring them back
to us and then the editorial layer
filters on something else which is is
this going to be an inexpensive story to
produce or an expensive story to produce
is this going to put the paper or the
radio program at risk is a TV station
going to be compromised if in fact there
is a legal response from some of the
participants and so I believe that the
institutional sympathies really live
much more in the editorial and
managerial layers than they do in the
reporting layers which causes a false
sense of security with people who are
well acquainted with reporters they tend
to say you know I know a lot of
reporters and I think of them as in
general having a lot of integrity and a
lot of passion but that's not the issue
the issue is that it's the composite the
interest is there a lot of times the
intelligence is there the grit is there
the drive is there what enervates the
system is when certain other concerns
that we know much less well enter the
story like for example is there an
advertiser or might be a pharmaceutical
firm that might be negatively impacted
by the story or for example is the legal
bill going to be large in order to
figure out whether or not the paper can
actually print this or is it going to be
expensive if the experts who are
involved in the story might have a
vested interest and so we have to figure
out some way around expert vested
interest in all of those situations you
can imagine that the layer above the
reporter is going to be much more
important than most people think and
that casual observers or even people
inside the industry will tend to place
too much of an emphasis on whether or
not there are good reporters available
one of the things I understood from your
podcast that was preventing people
reporting it before is the nature of
like if you look into this as a
journalist you immediately will go to
certain arbiters of truth to check it
out you'll go to for example the Medical
Association you'll go to various places
to check out the story and I guess one
of the reasons that this can't be
reported is that effectively everyone
that you go to check it with would have
a vested interest in it not
true is that part of the the issue what
are the wider I guess informational
journalistic perspectives that it shows
up well I know that my experience was
that for ten years I went to everybody I
could think of who would listen and I
told them what I knew and many of them
were quite interested including quite a
number of journalists who you know
couldn't believe the story they were
hearing and then they went to do
whatever it is journalists do and then
they became very strange and they
treated me like a pariah and I don't
know why that was but the implication is
that something somebody on the other end
of a phone said to them caused this
reaction now my point would be something
is synchronizing the reaction of people
on the other ends of phones that
journalists would call that is to say
the establishment has a system of
incentives that causes certain things to
be said that shut down the story now I
know what some of them were we've looked
at this there's no problem or this has
been addressed or we all know that the
mice are broken right all of these
things are easily answered if met on a
level playing field none of those are
proper concerns if the if the situation
has been addressed then it should leave
evidence in the literature that it's
been addressed if the situation is not a
problem that should also leave a
hallmark in the literature all the mice
are broken doesn't mean anything because
yes mice are not perfect model organisms
no organism is a perfect model organism
but the lab mouse telomeres appear to be
the result of a breeding protocol that
is sensitive to being altered in order
to change its affect on the lab mouse
telomeres so the fact that mice may be
broken with respect to this hormone or
that
hormone has nothing to say about whether
or not this thing that became broken on
the human watch could be unbroken and
they could be vastly better models so
there's no answer that anybody there's
no response that anybody heard that
doesn't invite the next question but in
general journalists are not molecular
biologists who are in a position to know
that what they're hearing is actual
[ __ ]
so they think that what they're hearing
is actually a proper response and that
that proper response therefore means
that whoever is pushing this is some
sort of a problem that needs
investigative journalism is therefore a
prank and I don't know what we do about
the fact that journalists don't have the
chops in general to figure out that what
they're getting on the other end of the
phone suggests the need for more
journalism not less maybe it involves
the vast overproduction of PhDs that we
currently engage in we produce lots of
people who never get a job inside of
academia maybe they need to become
journalists so that they have the idea
of what question asked next when they're
confronted with that kind of nonsense
but at the very least we can see not
only is the scientific system broken but
the journalistic system that's supposed
to keep the scientific system honest is
also broke one of the other stories that
you've tweeted about quite regularly and
it's sort of something that many memes
basically kind of trying to prevent the
story from dying is the Epstein case do
you do you get a sense of journalistic
incompetence or journalistic malpractice
in that story as well again when you say
journalistic I mean the composite of the
reporter together with the institution
for whom they are reporting it's a
little bit like a pigeon constantly
flying into some sort of obstruction it
appears to be in flight and then as the
pigeon gets farther and farther across
the room suddenly it's like it slams
into some kind of a force field now you
and I know that that's probably a
description of a glass wall
all right there is some glass wall that
is preventing the Epstein story from
being discussed properly everyone's
interested in the questions are basic
and there's a guaranteed story to write
simply ask the most basic questions of
the officials involved and print
whatever comes back whatever it is
there's no possibility of an
uninteresting answer to the central
questions and yet the central questions
are not asked and what other central
questions the first one is very simple
you have to ask every government that
might be involved was Jeffrey Epstein
known to be attached to any Intelligence
Agency anywhere in the world then you
have to ask where his pedophile
activities known to the intelligence
agencies and was there any kind of tacit
approval or understanding or is there a
categorical denial that such techniques
may never be used now we have not
recorded the no comments or we don't
discuss sources and methods that's
typical in these stories where you
should be able to say can I at least get
a statement that we would never condone
paedophile activities to be used for
intelligence gathering purposes all
right the next question Jeffrey Epstein
was supposed to be a hedge fund manager
of some kind and he had extensive
offices at a place called Villard house
the former Helmsley Palace this trophy
building is a place that I myself
dropped off materials for Jeffrey
Epstein to review in connection to a
hedge fund matter what I want to know is
where are the trading records from
Villard house it would be almost
impossible to go back in time and fake
trading records for a billion
dollar-plus hedge fund and yet nobody
seems to have ever recorded a trade with
Jeffrey Epstein we don't know where he
did prime brokerage there are no
financial records that explain his
fortune all those publicly available
should be publicly available I don't
even care about that where are the
records if there are no records I mean
presumably this person paid taxes
presumably this person had to make SEC
filings I don't know but the key issue
is I don't think there was a hedge fund
when I met Jeffrey Epstein
which might have been something like
2002 before he was charged with sex
crimes violations in Florida I did not
believe that Jeffrey Epstein was a hedge
fund manager and I in fact called my
wife at the time and I said this man
appears to be a construct and she said
what do you mean by a construct I said
he it's like they've hired an actor to
play a hedge fund manager but this
person didn't behave like the super rich
normally behaved he didn't behave like a
hedge fund manager behaved he didn't
have any of the substance that you would
normally associate with people of that
class I'm not saying he wasn't smart but
he was glib and he lived essentially
like he was Gatsby I only met him once
it's probably for about an hour or so
but he was an absolutely terrifying
person to encounter it would be
surprising to me if I was alone in that
I immediately had the suspicion that I
was looking at somebody who had been
constructed rather than something that
had organically arisen within the
financial community further questions
that need to be asked where was ghilane
Maxwell's passport last sighted assume
that she has one or more passports and
assume that government's record when
passports go through a border point okay
we should at least be able to ascertain
where was the last point where her
passports or at least one of her
passports were officially seen I don't
know if anybody asking this question can
we not call up Interpol is there no
sense in which we can guess where she
was last located where what was the last
social event in which she was recorded
we don't seem to know anything about
this person why are we not talking to
Les Wexner I don't understand why these
people are not being interviewed or
deposed we have a very strange situation
and in all of these cases a simple
declaration of no comment would be a
newsworthy story
I mean I'm hopeful I mean investigative
journalism does take time I'm hopeful
there I'll be kidding I really I'm gonna
shut you down on this it's been over six
months
this doesn't take that long to get a no
comment from the CIA nah no comment I'm
not talking about the no comment I'm my
point was going to be I given given the
amount of interest in the apps teen
story there must be some investigative
journalists working on it I completely
agree with your points about the no
comments like that being I'm sorry it's
not a question of some investigative
journalists we tripped over some
enormous structure we don't know what
this structure was yeah it doesn't make
any sense the the fortune that I think
I've seen reference to something like
six hundred million dollars who with six
hundred million dollars would make these
purchases you know multiple jet
aircrafts private islands you know a
townhouse on 71st Street and Manhattan a
huge comp complex in the New Mexico
desert property in Paris it would appear
that most of this was intended for
display I mean in other words the
behavior patterns of Jeffrey Epstein
suggests an eleven figure fortune maybe
high eleven figure fortune this person
appears to be somewhere in the nine
figures that's two orders of magnitude
off now I know that very rich is very
rich to many people but you know as a
person of much much smaller means I can
tell you that if you hang around with
people who are in this stratosphere they
behave very differently depending upon
which order of magnitude they're at and
Jeffrey Epstein was at the wrong order
of magnitude he was behaving like a high
eleven figure type guy maybe with what
appears to be a nine figure fortune yeah
I mean my my point on this is that I
don't I don't know where the media
interest is and and it doesn't add up
that there wouldn't be media interest
given that the the huge desire for the
story that you can kind of see every
time you log on anything any scrap is
interesting to everybody yeah especially
given that we already know the links to
someone like Prince Andrew the British
royal family this is one of the biggest
potentially one of
the biggest stories let's talk about has
ever has ever happened well let's talk
about the interview with Prince Andrew
what was that now I cannot believe my
ears when very intelligent people watch
that interview and its entirety and then
say well he was unprepared or it was a
mistake to grant that interview I think
that that's not true I think we have no
idea what that repu represented I think
that that interview was so bizarre and
so clearly it was almost like he was
trolling the media who was asking him
questions was he forced to give an
interview and he decided that he would
rather go down with the ship and give
the world's worst interview was he
realizing that he was completely trapped
and that his best strategy was to make
fun of the entire process by giving
answers that were so implausible that no
child would ever believe them
whatever that interview was was one of
the most remarkable pieces of footage
anybody has ever seen on television Bar
None to not be talking about this and
say we do not know what that interview
represented what was a member of the
British royal family
the Queen's son doing giving that
interview was it in Buckingham Palace
yes thank you most it was an insane
event that happened where nobody came to
a conclusion that makes that make any
sense I'd rather leave the problem open
who was forced to do what by whom that
that interview would ever be granted
yeah I can remember when it was first
announced having a sort of double take
of like this is not a good this is not
gonna go well and then the actual
interview happened I think it really
maybe for us for us right it was
effectively an admission that something
is so often the world something that's
so completely bizarre that that thing
would be produced that was some sort of
internal conflict I don't know whether
it was between the Queen and her son or
the intelligence services or I don't
know what but it was it was sort of the
sense that you have like almost a
hostage video where the person B has to
behave so bizarrely as to send a message
and the message I got is I'm going to
lie I'm going to fabricate I'm going to
say preposterous things in an effort to
just put this to bed in the worst
possible way like you want you now all
know never to ask me questions about
this because I'm simply gonna say the
most outrageous and insane things that I
can possibly think I mean as I said I it
it didn't twig at the beginning it
sounded like a terrible idea but then I
guess I rationalized it by thinking he's
clearly got no self-awareness maybe he
did think that he could clear his name
nobody's that dumb David those questions
were entirely expected and the answer is
if you look at the amount of twinkle in
the arm he's clearly not a happy man but
he's saying absolutely ludicrous and
preposterous things I think that the
effect is exactly the reverse if I had
to speculate I really don't want to I
would say that this this interview was
given because an amount of pressure was
put on a human being who decided that
his life was effectively over in most
senses and this is the way he chose to
go out effectively making fun of the
entire process yeah but what's really
interesting is I'm sort of aware for
example the Royal Television Society
Awards were tonight to go journalism
awards and the Prince Andrew interview
one scoop of the year and interview of
the year so it's kind of been
rationalized and I've seen people talk
about how they got the interview they
the news night producer was trying hard
and was on buckingham palace like which
is kind of ludicrous the idea that it
was just the the dedication of the
journalists keep continuing to ask for
an interview that made Prince Andrew say
okay you've asked me so many times I
mean that in itself is kind of a
ludicrous narrative but it is a
narrative that that the mainstream I've
seen the mainstream media kind of
integrate that whole thing into wow this
is an amazing scoop you were dedicated
and you've got the story which is which
is kind of ludicrous the idea that
so you see what I'm what I'm saying I
really don't I mean I'm so I'm so what
I'm saying is that it's already been
rationalized within the mainstream media
the reason that that interview happened
was because they were so dedicated and
they pursued Prince Andrew and they
asked Buckingham Palace and eventually
they they conceded they gave the
interview which is kind of ludicrous I'm
saying it's ludicrous oh it is ludicrous
but I guess I mean my expectation is
that even if the UK is no longer the
world power at once was I presume you
still have adults with IQs over 70 how
could you possibly rationalize such a
thing I mean we used to turn to you guys
for intelligence and sophistication this
seems the height of folly if I had that
say this is much closer to a hostage
video where the hostage is attempting to
send a message that is clearly not the
ostensibly John video the really
difficult part of the story David is is
that almost certainly we're talking
about some kind of operation that was
being run with knowledge of governments
that may have involved pedophilia and
was not shut down and what I can't
understand is what is it that is keeping
some reporter from simply asking the
questions that are on everybody's mind
was this person connected to the
intelligence services where was Gillian
Maxwell's passport last seen why are we
not talking to less wexter where are the
trading records what is the source of
the fortune
it seems to me very clear that we have a
missing fortune of robert maxwell an
unexplained fortune of Jeffrey Epstein
are those the same fortune
who's asking these questions did
everybody go to sleep when they taught
journalism in school I just don't
understand I guess my sort of disconnect
as well is this sense of I worked in
Channel 4 News they had an investigative
unit these were the kind of
bread-and-butter questions they pushed
really hard for example on the phone
hacking scandal in the UK that the
Murdoch papers phone hacking scandal
that also involved networks of power it
involved shady deals and involved
corruption and they they pursued that
quite intensely I I'm feeling
a sense of dislocation because I agree
with you there are these questions that
are not being asked and I find it
difficult to understand why that is
knowing that there are knowing that the
public interest and knowing the that
that these are questions have been asked
in the past let me tell you what
happened people started asking those
questions and they stopped and that's
what ideas suppression is all about we
don't have the resources to pursue that
right now well actually I'm concerned
that this is starting to reek of
conspiracy theory I think given the
delicacies of the situation I'm gonna
need a lot more evidence before I give
this thing that go ahead these are the
sorts of things that you say when you're
trying to shut down a line of inquiry
and my guess is is that whatever the
story is it represents some very
powerful structure that we tripped over
and I tripped over that structure in
2002 and I was convinced at the time
before there was any knowledge about
this Florida situation that this was
constructed I mean we have a very famous
case of a guy named le Cohen who was
fitted with a backstory and became a
Playboy in Damascus and held orgies if I
understand correctly where he collected
information and leverage against people
in the Syrian government if you take
that situation this looks remarkably
similar we've got a guy who was
apparently a math teacher at a private
high school and the next thing we know
he's avoided jail in some sort of
financial scandal and he suddenly set up
as a mystery financier with connections
to absolutely everyone in the top
echelon zuv power something doesn't
smell right about the story given that
nobody appears to have ever traded
currencies with the guy who was
apparently moving billions as a currency
trader and was this kind of well known
within the within the financial industry
at the time there were two fortunes that
were truly mysterious Bernie Madoff and
Jeff Epstein in the case of Bernie
Madoff the belief was that he had a
legitimate business and an illegitimate
business and he used the
legitimate business as a source of
profit by front-running it inside of his
illegitimate business that turned out
not to be the case in fact it was
basically a Ponzi scheme and that leaves
Jeffrey Epstein now I used to give talks
in the world of finance about how to
handle opaque hedge funds like when they
won't give you information about what
they're doing and I conflated Jeffrey
Epstein and Bernie Madoff into one slide
and I called it as a joke Black Arts
capital because you had black stone and
black rock and so I turned it into black
arts and their tagline was supposed to
be we tell you what we were doing but
then we'd have to kill you so these were
well-known anomalies in New York in
financial circles because when when are
we talking what's one of the era you
know 2002 when I met Jeffrey Epstein
when he tried talking to me about
currency trading so it was well known
with financial journalists little well
known that the fortune didn't make sense
something didn't add up who is his prime
broker who was he trading with under
what name where did this money come from
why did he seem to know everybody
he was like somebody created it Gatsby
like character out of a Ralph Lauren
look-alike who had apparently recently
been a math teacher at a private high
school nothing made nothing added up and
is the sense now that even interest in
this story kind of mocks you out as a
conspiracy theorist you know I don't
like the question but he's easy is that
your service yeah no no I mean I attack
the question would you mind sure okay
what do you mean a conspiracy theorist
so when I hear nightly on the news that
maybe Russia is controlling the American
elections and trying to prop Donald
Trump up are those conspiracy theories
when I hear that the coronavirus is in
fact under control and then the market
falls apart is that a conspiracy theory
I mean where are we in history that
conspiracy theorizing is a privilege of
the people inside the institutional
class now
that's incompetent we have discovered
conspiracies previously in the United
States COINTELPRO is probably the most
disturbing conspiracy that we found
within the last 50 years in fact
conspiracies happen and you need to be
able to go after them so I think we
should make a new rule the next person
who tries to use the epithet conspiracy
theorist we figure out what conspiracy
theory they've been pushing because
frankly everybody inside of the gated
institutional narrative is Hawking one
conspiracy theory or the other it's time
for this technique of trying to
intimidate people by using that epithet
to die and if you want to come after me
be my guest
do it in print and let's have some fun
we have to understand that in episode 18
which we were previously discussing I
introduced the disc the reason for doing
it right before episode 19 where I talk
about the telomere situation the Jackson
Laboratory in the Grider Laboratory was
is that I didn't want to explain what
the disc was only I wanted to show
people what the disc is in a normal
world given the amount of interest in
that story if what I'm saying is untrue
or whether in fact is true whether what
Brett is saying is true or untrue every
possible outcome is interesting every
possible outcome could sell papers ergo
if the thing is not being followed up
and in fact you can demonstrate the
amount of interest by looking at the
amount of interest on the web you can
figure out very clearly that there is a
disc because nobody would forego those
that large a number of eyeballs and that
many clicks if they actually had a
proven story so in part the way you
understand the disc is to ask what
doesn't happen so for the moment just
imagine that you have two layers you
have a physical and legacy media layer
and you have a digital layer what is
remarkable is the extent to which the
physical and legacy layer comprised of
things that exist in the world
institutions legacy media ignores this
other layer it
occasionally you get sparks between the
two layers and when those sparks happen
you get magic now what I find
fascinating is the way in which the
legacy media layer is pretending that
very smart people with the same
credentials that are found in the lower
layer are saying interesting things and
there is almost like an agreement to
treat them as vampires that is when they
pass by the looking-glass of legacy
media
there should be no reflection that
something interesting is being said that
is gaining adherence and I think that's
what's fascinating to me if you think
about what the portal has done it's had
people like Sir Roger Penrose the great
physicist on it's had Tyler Cowen who
writes perhaps the most read economics
block on Peter Thiel one of the most
listened to voices in Silicon Valley all
of these people are saying interesting
things and yet there's effectively no
reflection of what's going on outside of
this legacy media arena so what you have
is you have an insular system that is
the gated institutional narrative and
you have an insulating layer which is
the disk that prevents anybody who's not
part of the institutional agreements
from saying something super interesting
and having it reflected inside of the
institutional conversation and I think
that that's what the point of the portal
is how do we find a way to arc between
the digital and the legacy layer because
actually the legacy layer isn't
important to me in terms of reaching
people the reach of a Joe Rogan or a sam
Harris or me or Brett or any of these
people is more than sufficient to get
the news out there the real importance
of the legacy layer is that there is an
agreement that we are not going to take
seriously that which is solely digital
and so if we can just stick our fingers
in our ears long enough or pretend that
everybody outside of the Citadel is Alex
Jones and a Matt and mad as a hatter
with a tinfoil hat then we can protect
potentially pretend that just like in
professional wrestling
everything is real and nothing is fake
and that's the that's the new fate of
litigated institutional narrative people
are increasingly taking a look at it and
saying there is no telling of the tale
that results in what you are currently
calling journalism we are all seeing
this extra layer and you guys are
pretending that it doesn't even exist do
you think that insulating layer has got
more intent since because in 2016 you
did have like Trump effectively kind of
coming out of the online insurgency and
changing and winning the election do you
think that there is more insulation
between the digital layer in there and
we just look at all of the changes in
the Terms of Service yeah so for example
look at the Terms of Service of Facebook
of Twitter of Google between then and
now and look at all of the terms we've
learned right I mean I think Google had
a leaked report called the good sensor I
believe that Twitter uses down ranked to
mean shadow banning I believe that
Facebook uses D boosting the entire
conversation we now have a doctrine of
strategic silence coming out of the data
and society group about why reporters
should not talk about things I mean the
institution's had a wake up call which
is Donald Trump proves the power of the
digital layer the people are angry
they're sick of the stuff nobody
believes in the institution's I don't
think the people who man the
institution's believe in the
institution's they're all sick with the
same problem and in that in kind of an
environment they've all gone to
desperate measures to defend themselves
by making sure that they have the means
of keeping anything unwanted out of that
layer so before it was an allegation I'm
being shadow bin and they would say well
we don't we don't do that now that's
part of the Terms of Service now I don't
think that there's anything controlling
all of the different ways that ideas are
suppressed
but the central thesis that I have is
that since the early 1970s period
between 1971 and 1973 let's say
something changed in the nature of the
world economy and whatever this changes
we didn't study it enough we didn't talk
about it enough people will say oh I
know exactly what that is it's the Arab
oil shock or it's the change in the
relationship to the gold standard but in
fact something changed character and it
meant that all of our institutions that
were built on an expectation of growth
could suddenly no longer meet their
expect their expectations that were put
upon them as a result my belief is is
that we had a universal environmental
effect which is that all of the
institutions came to be headed by people
who were comfortable in one form or
another with distorting the truth and as
the situation went on longer the heads
of the institutions became more
aggressive in the way that they would
distort the truth to hide the fact that
the pyramid scheme that we discussed in
your last film was governing everything
that you couldn't get enough entrance
into the system in order to feed the
system by telling them the truth alright
so in this situation what happens we
have a very thorny problem if people
start discussing the idea that things
are patterned or built as pyramid
schemes then every single institution
becomes endangered and if one
institution is more honest and another
one less honest than the more honest one
will tend to suffer as a result we
became more and more aggressive towards
individuals on behalf of our
institutions dissenters people who would
actually raise the question of our
universities actually giving a good
education and delivering value for the
money that they cost or is it likely
that this law firm has a durable
business model or is this medical
practice too governed by incentives
coming from
the pharmaceutical industry in order to
keep afloat all of these sorts of
questions became very important to
suppress and as a result I would say
lots of different pieces started to
emerge that would suppress questioning
and suppress disruptive ideas so it
might in my understanding of this all of
these different complexes sort of begin
to interweave into a master complex it
was an emergent phenomenon but because
the etiology was universal that is every
institution was protecting itself from
the fact that it could no longer meet
its growth expectations
unless cheating of some kind occurred
the threat they all faced was a common
threat that is that somebody would point
out that the medicine wasn't as good as
it was claimed the education was
overpriced and didn't deliver enough
value that our representatives were on
the take whatever the individual issues
were it needed to come to pass that the
institutions would be defended
generically against people asking
difficult questions so if you think
about the period still in the 1970s
before this had really kind of
solidified and hardened you had
institutions going after other
institutions for example 60 minutes and
CBS News would take on a corporation
that was misbehaving and so you know the
the old joke is one of the most
frightening words in the English
language Mike Wallace is here to see you
and the entire thrust of that was that
you would have institutional warfare for
example the Washington Post would take
on the presidency during the Watergate
era and somehow we now have a
gentlemen's agreement when we had the
2008 financial crisis I think
effectively no personnel at the
investment banks went to jail when we
had a savings and loan crisis we did
have people going to jail
so as time has gone on
somehow it has emerged that there's kind
of a sensibility as the different pieces
of ideas suppression form a giant
complex and the general feature is
always the same which is that the
dissenting individual has to be
suppressed or held back by the
institution because it's not right to
question an institution that can't
actually defend itself on its merits and
I think that you know you start to look
for this everywhere and you'll find it
for example on social media you'll see
people talking about D boosting or down
ranking in the me to scandal we learn a
new phrase that we never heard catch
catch and kill whatever these things are
when you start to hear well someone so
is disgruntled why are they disgruntled
why does that discount their perspective
maybe we should listen to disgruntled
people what we have is we have an
enormous complex that has arisen from
different pieces that are all somehow
interoperable because they're all
solving the same problem how do we make
sure that institutions that can no
longer defend themselves in honest terms
are protected from the individuals that
would raise the questions and you've
talked about before the gated
institutional narrative how is the the
disc different from the gates and
institutional narrative or the Djinn
that you talked about before well in the
case of the the Djinn it is a
conversation so it's the conversation
for example with the New York Times is
having with the Democratic Party with
commentary from the Atlantic and
analysis provided by The Economist so in
that sort of institutional conversation
all of the major players are talking the
disc is about the layer that separates
that conversation from the conversation
taking place outside of this sort of
rarefied exchange of ideas so what if
the person who is most knowledgeable
about something isn't attached to any
institution all that person has no
allegiance as the individuals remain
sovereign
as a result it's very important to make
sure that we don't have individuals
without institutional supervision or
attachment running around and
stimulating thought and questions about
various topics so I would say that the
gin is the thing that is being protected
by the disc Eric thank you very much
David pleasure as always well done for
making it to the end just wanted to let
you know a few things we've got coming
up including the biggest event we've
ever done the rebel wisdom festival
which will be a mix of ideas and
dialogues between people like Daniel
schmeckt and Berger Rupert Sheldrake
Jamba Vicki and many more and because
wisdom isn't just intellectual it's also
about practice will be offering
experiences like circling different
interpersonal dialogue mindfulness
breathwork
and many other with world-class
facilitators we're also running our
first online course called sense making
101 and if you're enjoying the content
you can help us make more by joining the
rebel wisdom Club which will give you
discounts on the courses and the events
and also access to a load more content
on the website including all of our live
events it'll also give you access to our
growing community which is something we
want to make a real focus for 2020
adding more meetups and other services
for members so I hope you enjoyed the
film and see you soon
you